okay now i'm going to give you i said
three different strategies right
mercifully for you the last two
strategies
are much quicker it's just that this is
kind of like the chief one so i wanted
to start out with that
sign was what we just had a look at show
that something positive
or negative and then you can get to the
result that you're after
this one down here i'm going to rub this
now this second strategy
is that you can also not just take two
things and compare one
to be bigger than the other you can
actually have a string of them you can
link these
together um i was going to say like
voltron but that's too old a reference
to you guys so
what's a robot that combines together
mrs lee's i don't know anyway hey mr saw
you can help me out
yeah power rangers you guys anyway okay
so
this is the name that i give to this
idea that you can link
inequalities together by saying you know
in fact i'll write it down for you uh if
you've got
three things and you know their order if
you've got three objects three
mathematical like numbers functions
whatever
if you know for instance that a is
greater than b
and that in turn if i link onto that
that's greater than c
what can you tell me about the
relationship between a and c
yeah a is bigger than c because like i'm
bigger than you and you're bigger than
you i was going to make a statement
about like the australian open and like
play tennis players beating other tennis
players and then i realized oh no you
can't because
sometimes this guy actually can but it's
like scissors paper rock situation
so we're not going to get to whirling
into that this implies
a is greater than c so really really
quick example have a look at this
inequality with p's and q's that i've
just handed to you down the bottom of
the board
i want to prove that p over q is going
to be greater than this
fraction here now if all you knew about
was the kind of strategies we looked at
here you're somewhat in trouble
spoilers okay you might say i'll do my
left hand side
take away right hand side thing okay i
just invite you right now
just write down the first line you don't
have to take it any further just write
down the first line
of left hand side take away right hand
side for this
and then think about where are you going
to go
next you're like i don't know common
denominators
i'll save you some time just ends up a
mess of p's and q's there's no
there's no obvious squares there's no
obvious reciprocals you're just like i
don't know what to do here
okay but if you're thinking about this
and maybe a numerical example might help
you here
not as a proof but to help you think
about the structure of your proof
this is like a one i was going to say
two lines but it's not even two lines
this is like a one and a half line
proof just by using linked
inequalities think about this with me
give me an example of a p over q just
think of a couple numbers whatever you
like
2 over 5 2 over 5
2 over 5 shot 2 over
5. do you agree i can make an ordering
statement
about this fraction if for instance
i said well let's just take that
numerator and subtract one
like so regret that what's the ordering
same what's the inequality that you can
say
between these two fractions
thank you i know it's the end of the day
but we know that two-fifths
is bigger than one-fifth why do you
think by the way i subtracted
one
because because that's what the question
is asking right now i can go again
i can go one step further because i just
dealt with the numerator there right i
can make another statement that a fifth
i can make this smaller again but not by
changing the numerator let's change the
denominator this time what should i do
to it
i should add one to it well i can add
anything that i want so long as i'm
making it bigger
like say six clearly even though you're
like i didn't need to
do this like because numbers but here
it's not quite so clear because it's all
algebraic does that make sense so here
comes my one and a half line proof i'm
just gonna do this
but algebraically rather than
numerically okay here we go so i can say
p
over q is bigger than what was what was
the first thing that i did
yeah i just changed my numerator i think
i subtracted didn't i
numerator's got to get smaller yeah so
it's p minus 1
over q that's an uncontroversial
statement okay
and then i go this is my extra half a
line right
i go and i change my denominator instead
when you increase
the size of a denominator you reduce the
size of the entire fraction so here goes
p minus 1 over
q plus 1. happy with that
now this linked inequality thing it's
going gonna happen actually we kind of
already did a little bit of it by doing
this you see here
what we were doing we had something
that's greater than or equal to zero
then it was greater than zero so you
actually have it sort of tucked away in
there implicitly
question i'll come to you in a second so
first we have this it's called the psi
of p and q as the the positive positive
position
and all that so yes yes
in that case q cannot be negative one
so in this case here right what you'll
see is every question you're about to do
in exercise
2d um it's going to have not just the
thing that they want you whether i write
it the thing that they want you to prove
but they also make a long and somewhat
boring string of qualifiers
on what kind of number what kind of
numbers are p
and q are they real are they integers
are they positive are they negative
right why are they all there
yes exactly when you can think about
like weird counter examples for this if
you have a look at
trivial cases that make sense you also
had a question manual
okay i'm glad i made your approval thank
you all right so
i i promised three strategies right
number one was looking for the
start to the nest sign prove it's
positive or negative or find some
appropriate related object that you can
prove positive or negative
the second one was about linking
together or stringing together
a set of inequalities and then the last
one strategy
number three i think i can write it up
here strategy number three
is to start with a
given result let me say that again you
want to start with a
given result and many of your proofs
will kind of what they're trying to do
is give you a leg
up into the result that you're trying to
prove so you know
use the stepping stone they provided
that given result and then use that as a
launch pad i'm mixing metaphors here
um to prove whatever result you want so
here's
an example that i pulled out already
given so here's my launch pad
a squared oh is it a squared it is 2.
plus b squared is greater than 2 a b
proof
okay all right so
what we're talking about here now as
i've just kind of flagged for you right
it's just like a
a big hey i'm trying to get your
attention here if they give you some
important result
i mean maybe you could prove this some
other way but i'm trying to give i'm
trying to give you a hand here right
trying to help you out so
how can we use this um and by the way
all the normal
caveats like a b and c they're all
distinct we're dealing with real numbers
of course
you might be able to see for instance
like oh i can think about this kind of
thing
happening that's going to be useful to
me potentially
how will i go about this hmm
remember i mean i said to you before
this is our launch pad right i'm going
to use this
as my starting point so
in my proof the first thing i'm going to
state is their result and then i want to
think about
is there some way that i can um no that
wasn't one i wanted is that is there
some way that i can use this
to progress into what the question
is now do you asking a suggestion or a
question
a question yeah if that statement is not
given
can i just quote this straight away uh
this this year
short answer no um so
you know part of the reason why we're
saying that it's given
is so that you know you don't have to
prove it but if i don't
then you probably need to prove it right
um you know you know these things i said
before though here these under these
strategies
these things you don't have to prove and
that's kind of why i gave them to you
right
but pretty much everything else you have
the tools you have the knowledge
go for it okay so
i have this statement i already know
this to be true but the thing that i'm
trying to prove it has like not just a's
and b's in it
it's got c's any suggestion how i could
potentially use this result
to help me get toward here what do you
think
okay did you quite catch that right
what's happening here you actually gave
us
you guys the whole proof okay so let's
just paddle back for a moment
this result here which is given right i
know this to be true
but it doesn't have all the pro numerals
that i want so i some have to introduce
them
now a b and c just all being regular old
numbers
i can do some substitution here can't i
right instead of having a b
here there's no reason why i can't
substitute c which would mean
that the right hand side is not 2a b
it's 2a
c no big deal now this is promising
because you're like oh i've got the a
squareds and the b squareds and the c
squareds and then you just kind of are
ticking off for yourself i've got a bs
and acs
have a look at the result we're trying
to prove what's missing yeah there's bc
here right
so i'm going to go and substitute this
for c so i'll write this
2 bc okay now in order to then
go further and again parham suggested we
take a sum here right
i need to be able to refer to each of
these inequalities so i'm going to give
them
names just so i rather than saying those
things up there so
let's give them names like so just like
you've been used to doing
in simultaneous equations except they're
simultaneous inequalities
what would be your next line to get you
to the next flow of logic
being that i've just named these i'm
going to add them right
and i've just given them names so i can
say 1 plus 2
plus 3. add all my left hand sides add
all my right hand sides and i'm going to
get
a nice equation here so don't skip this
step by the way
it's tempting to start simplifying
immediately
but this topic is after all called proof
so show me everything don't skip what
have i got here 2a b
2 a c 2 b c
i'll leave it as an exercise to the
reader to do the immense amount of work
left between here and the result you're
trying to prove does that make sense
can you see here that often the hard
part is actually not the algebra
it's the thinking through what's the
path through this question
and also it's about setting up your
logic appropriately
not beginning with the thing that you're
trying to prove and then manipulating
and like wow amazing i proved that it
was true
it's because you started there make
sense
now where we're going to finish up is
all of the stuff we've been looking at
that is
uh algebraic inequality specific all
this like oh you can do different things
to this side or you just look at
prove that the left hand side minus
right hand side is positive all that
business right
that's specific to inequalities but
please remember
that everything else you've learned
within this topic is still
tools in your toolbox so if you have a
look at a question like this
the question doesn't give you any clues
partly because
like what's marvelous about this is
there's at least three
and i know way more uh at least three
distinct ways you could go about proving
this
and part of the fun is can i think about
like what's the most
efficient way to get there the laziest
and least amount of work
one of our favorites that we learned
like last week is the proof by
contradiction right and this is a really
good candidate
for proof by contradiction think with me
how does a proof by contradiction
structure and i've given you a big clue
right from the outset what's the thing
that i'm assuming
yeah the inverse which is a plus b
squared is
less than boy hmm you're so very close
i'm going to be very mean and cruel you
said assume the inverse the inverse
actually is
a thing in logic but it's actually a
separate thing it's not within the scope
of the course you can do some things
with it if you want
but actually the thing that we want is
not the inverse of this
has another name starts with an n it's
the negation and actually means
they mean subtly different things so do
be careful okay um the word we used was
opposite and that's kind of like
colloquial
negation is the real technical term you
mean inverse
is another technical term again what
does the negation
of this look like it's actually very
easy when you're dealing with algebra
yeah i i don't want it to be greater
than or equal to
i just flip that thing around and i also
don't include
the boundary case right so what i want
to show is that if i go
from here i should be able to do some
manipulation to this thing and land on
something absurd something contradictory
makes sense
let's have a go right what's your first
instinct what could we do with this
i'll just expand it see what happens
right let's have it go i'm going to get
a squared
plus 2 plus 2a b plus b squared happy
times
nothing's happened to the right hand
side what is the most obvious thing
jumping out at you now
yeah i'm going to collect some like
terms that leaves me with
minus 2 a b on this side and once you've
written that
on the left hand side again there's
another thing jumping out at you what
can you do here
i can factorize it back and factorizing
it back gives you something
that is puzzling right because you can
say
hang on hang on i'm squaring something
apparently that's
negative now we know that can happen but
not in this world right not within this
domain so the structure of the proof i
would say but
right i can say a and b
a and b are real right
therefore i'll just that implies that a
minus b or squared a minus b
all squared that has to be this right
that's what like what i can do with real
numbers
but these two statements together
especially right
after one another now i can say it's a
contradiction so
contradiction
put an exclamation mark for a dramatic
effect and then that means that whatever
i began
with my assumption which is you know led
to this contradiction
that must be false so i can say this
thing here
a plus b all squared is less than 4
a b i've just established that can't
possibly be true so i put
a dash through it and so the negation of
this is what i started with
therefore a plus b all squared must be
greater than
or equal to right so even though a
question may not explicitly say hey use
proof by contradiction use proof by
contraposition remember
these tools often make things a lot
easier for you
okay any questions